let's talk about the seditious
conspiracy this is this is the big play
the democrats needed they needed to be
able to say that there were sedition
charges for their narrative you've got
the daily show now coming out saying the
no sedition you know uh talking point is
now officially dead rest in peace in
memoriam we have this story from cnn
oathkeeper's leader appears in court on
seditious conspiracy charges but it
wasn't just him it was ten others so you
want to break down for us what this is
about yes i'd like to say some things
about this first of all the can
seditious conspiracy charge is a rare
one and it's one that's even more
rarely used successfully if you look at
the history of it um there's only a
handful of cases the first couple cases
are weird like uh cases involving puerto
rico for whatever reason then you have
uh one successful case against an
islamic terrorist and you have a couple
others that were not successful so this
is a very rare charge it's an extremely
serious charge
everyone else i believe on the uh who is
charged with seditious conspiracy they
already had
lesser charges the only person who has
just added completely was the founder
and leader of the oath keeper stewart
rhodes and i think there's probably a
lot of public interest in
a reaction to this particularly because
my news outlet revolver.news has run
several
detailed investigative reports on rhodes
calling into question the seeming
protection that he enjoyed from the
federal government for not being
arrested and so forth and so i think a
lot of people are confused and some
people are probably erroneously
concluding oh he was hit with this
charge therefore
um he couldn't have been a fed and uh i
think
the there are a number of things to say
for that first of all i don't think any
of the questions raised in the
revolver's reporting are dispelled by
this i think they're only intensified
and here's some interesting things about
his case so seditious conspiracy is a
very serious charge so we're we're
supposed to believe that the
government's been building this serious
charge for an entire year and yet they
didn't bother to search him for an
entire year
well asterisk to that they searched a
single cell phone on his person four
months
after january six so here's the founder
and leader of the most prosecuted
boogeyman militia group was all over the
media and he's so dangerous
that they wait four months give him four
months to destroy all evidence and take
a single cell phone from his person and
then wait an additional eight months of
zero search before they hit him with
this serious charge if they're taking
him seriously enough to hit him with
seditious conspiracy how do you explain
the fact
that they only took a single cell phone
four months after and contrast that with
an individual called thomas caldwell who
is one of his co-defendants now
caldwell
was arrested very early on in
mid-january
caldwell got the full
fed raid treatment where they went in
with guns they raided his place they
took every electronic in sight
then they charged him immediately with a
conspiracy charge to obstruct an
official proceeding
and if you look at the conspiracy
charging documents
the whole conspiracy of the government's
case is based on stuart rhodes's
statements and actions
and so that raises another question
about rhodes's seditious conspiracy
indictment why did the feds wait an
entire year
for this big indictment when they could
have taken him off the streets with a
lesser indictment either for the same
conspiracy charge that they hit thomas
caldwell for and others
or a trespassing charge which we know he
trespassed there's footage of him
on the capitol grounds and they've
charged others with trespassing even who
didn't go into the capital so putting
these things together you have to wonder
okay they they were taking him so
seriously that they were building up
this mega seditious conspiracy case
through the course of a whole year and
yet in that year they only search a
single cell phone four months after
january 6 and they neglect the option to
hit him with a lesser charge and just do
a superseding indictment
for the seditious case so those are
really important questions that linger
and i think the seditious conspiracy
charge is actually a way for the
government to get away with the perfect
crime and i'd love to explain that but
i'll i'll stop here do you think that
rhodes is a fed or in some way involved
with feds
i think that that is the most powerful
explanation for the questions that i
just raised when you guys say fed you
mean a federal agent not necessarily a
federal bureau of investigators yeah fed
is a vague term i think that
the most likely explanation for the
questions that i raised was that he had
some relationship with some
government agency
is it is it possible that
the reason they didn't go after them
early on the reason they didn't try and
dredge up any other information was
because they knew there was none and the
only reason they're bringing charges now
is that it's an election year and it
justifies establishment political
talking points um i think that would be
a plausible explanation if none of the
other people were charged but if they
knew there was no information then how
did they get this guy thomas caldwell on
conspiracy where the whole conspiracy
and the charging documents
is full of stuart rhodes's statements
and actions so if they thought that
amounted to nothing how do you explain
that they hit this minor figure who's
just a fellow traveler not even an oath
keeper and this guy who's built up as
the big boogie man head of the oath
keepers they leave him untouched and
unsearched here's my here you know i see
all of the uh
the the daily show did that thing where
it was like you know um
rest in peace the there was no sedition
charges talking point yeah i just
respond with has anybody been convicted
of insurrection or sedition even well
innocent until proven guilty
if the government says you are there's
going to be no no conviction and i
here's what i will either look i'll i'll
be uh look
when a lot of people came out and said
was anybody charged with sedition or
insurrection we've brought that talking
point up as well and it's it's relevant
up until the government decides to do it
right so i'll say this right now maybe
someone will be convicted but the
talking point isn't that it'll ever
happen is for right now with the january
6 committee coming out and saying all of
these things right just because you
charge someone i don't care
when these people are convicted we can
have a conversation about right you know
that we found in a court of law they
they attempted to do these things and
that being said the federal government
when they charge people they have a very
very high conviction rate
so is this good except for seditious
conspiracy ironically except for so just
two more really important points about
rhodes in particular in this charge one
is the timing okay part of the timing
was the whole you know fed surrection
narrative was at its absolute apex i
think more important than that though
is just
like a week before rhodes was charged
an attorney for another oath keeper
subpoenaed rhodes and was getting him to
testify
in the oath keepers case and one
consequence of actually charging roads
is it clears him off the table so that
he has a perfect excuse not to testify
because he just please the fifth and
this is part of the playbook in fact it
happened in the michigan case one of the
big informants in that case was named
steve robson once he was outed
the government immediately slapped him
with an unrelated gun charge that clears
him off the table so that's one aspect
that i think is really important in
relation to the timing another thing is
this is if i were the feds
and i wanted to cover up the perfect
crime
i would do precisely what they just did
with the seditious conspiracy charge for
the following reasons think of what the
charge achieves one
it gives a big headline that for lower
information people or people don't
really understand the argument they say
oh he's hit with this charge he must not
be a fed so it quote unquote debunks the
right wing people who say oh fed
surrection
on the other hand it assuages and
satisfies all of these left-wing people
who have been furious that he hasn't
been charged for a year because in their
minds the government is protecting him
because the government's a bunch of
trump-loving nazis so it assuages them
but thirdly there's a problem if they
hit roads with a serious charge and
rhodes is a fed then rhodes has leverage
over them and could say i'm going to go
rogue if you guys betray me
but i think they have the perfect cover
story for that too because they could go
to roads and say look we're going to hit
you with a seditious conspiracy charge
it's going to sound serious but the
public story is you are going to
cooperate and get tell us what you know
about alex jones tell us what you know
about roger stone just smear a bunch of
dirt on trump's inner circle which is
what the media wants more than anything
and so the public story will look like
oh rhodes is cooperating because he's
giving up trump's inner circle and so
they won't follow through the charges
and so
they don't
force
roads to go rogue they shut up the feds
erection quote-unquote conspiracy
theorists on the right they shut up the
people on the left who are furious he
wasn't charged and they put more dirt on
trump's inner circle all in one move so
i think i'm not saying that's ex that's
necessarily what it is but if i were
consulting with the feds and saying
what's the most elegant solution to this
problem that you're in right now this
looks pretty close it would also shatter
the oath keepers i would imagine by
ripping the head off the snake well let
me just let me just point out
one temporarily i need to point out one
very obvious and definitive fact
the the the federal officers here are
conspiracy theorists oh they've they've
not proven any conspiracy they've
actually just theorized a conspiracy
took place and have yet to prove it to
anybody so for the time being a bunch of
conspiracy theorists are seeding
information to cnn who reports it as
fact mind you the reporter i won't say
or say her name is one of the lead
reporters in russiagate
i'm sorry i'm sorry i got that one wrong
that one wrong that was wrong not not
that reporter that was the russia thing
but uh i'll just leave it at that and i
got that one mixed up
yes and just in in in light of this
conspiracy theory it you're absolutely
right and you're right in the literal
sense benny thompson who is the chair of
the january 6 committee in his personal
capacity
sued
trump
roger stone
oath keepers and proud boys and laid out
his literal conspiracy theory which is
that trump's inner circle colluded with
the proud boys and oath keepers in order
to do january 6. that's actually the
conspiracy theory which is weird because
given the prominent role that stuart
rhodes played in the january 6th
chairman's theory he waited until
november to subpoena roads i find that
also a little bit weird and he only did
that after revolver news uh put on the
pressure by saying what the hell is
going on with the committee they're
neglecting roads and they're going after
seemingly anyone who was within a mile
radius of the capital on january 6 and
taking their phones and communications
and so forth
so where does it go
well they're not going to convict him
i i think that's extremely unlikely and
i but i think a very interesting dynamic
is in play um a very interesting dynamic
is in play i think these are
um there it's an elegant attempt but
it's also a risky attempt because the
the more that they do this just like
their cover up with epps saying oh epps
isn't a fed because ebbs talked to the
committee and told us he wasn't a fed
without releasing epson's exact
statements and without even telling us
that
uh epson's statement was under oath and
it's a weirdly precise statement of eps
not being a law enforcement official
well dod is not law enforcement there
are a lot of other agencies that aren't
law enforcement that he may have been
affiliated thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
p.m and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time